good morning Millennials
good morning Millennials good morning
Millennials
it sounds like robbing mmm
my back is broken from that's why
Claudia so I got a blowout this morning
because I watch myself on the show
yesterday and I was like damn I do look
unkempt and it's really not fair how
like I could spend all day on my makeup
my outfit from Chanel is my hair is not
done I look like a mess like that really
is what it is that's how I feel today
I'm know my bun looks cute tonight you
were wearing Chanel yesterday you know
the impact it's a metaphor it's a
metaphor
it's an analogy ever heard of it look it
up sweetie and so I just decided to get
a blog this morning also cuz I have a
show tonight and I just didn't want to
do it myself so I woke up like extra
early I planned out and like I was
literally ready at 8:45 right so I had a
full hour just like to do everything how
scary
so what did I do because even when you
only have five minutes you're just
making basket I went live on Instagram
so I was having a good time and you know
I got a requests just saying shallow and
you know I'm nobody not to turn down a
request so I sang it and like that part
where she goes oh like I gave it
everything and it was on like honestly
I've never sounded so good in my whole
life it's a video saved on your
Instagram I never saved my story they
like freaked me out I mean my life my
life it freaks me out
but I was like so shocked by my own
Talent and literally I was physically
exhausted afterwards I had to in love so
your back hurt from singing shallow No
my back hurt from nailing the note like
so powerfully I gave it my whole body
which note
[Music]
all in one breath that's why this Jackie
like I my back hurts like I need to go
to a get a massage well I'm sorry for
you know I know a lady Gaga has a
masseuse with me I'll give you a massage
and I'm at the express spa in Livadia
always your plan and it always yeah look
I didn't get a manicure so terrible so
you're going in the express fun I have
plans
Express call Atlanta cool do you want a
ski that my side chair oh yeah sorry
cool sweatshirt where'd you get it being
sister I got it directly from H&M Club
no like a wiener I woke up at 8:00 a.m.
for the drop you did I did I said an
alarm it was like three weeks ago and I
didn't get anything it was like all I
couldn't get anything in my cart but I
was already working on like some
influencer gifting
they didn't think I was gonna pan out
and they really was happy to buy it and
they wanted to buy the things that I
wanted as opposed to like crossing my
fingers are requesting stuff and then
like being like a pig cuz I really
wanted everything and they sent me about
flow goodies and I'm just I'm so happy
it's like never happens ever and Ivy Lee
asked
believed and received that's the thing
about manifest destiny it happens it
works and I was destined to wear 18 EMA
skeino and he manifested it so and I
received it ask believe receive I asked
I believed I received what's better than
that not much and he's we have a great
show for you guys today of course so
much because not only do we have the
fash I stories I added a bonus story
because I just couldn't choose it's like
picking your favorite children then we
have special guest digging out Caroline
who is just like a flow inspiration to
me but a lot of you toasters have
actually found out about the show
through her so I'm so excited to talk to
her because she's also a toaster and an
influencer toaster like might have the
greatest combination of all time right
might have some influential advice for
us and the third reason why today's show
is so [ __ ] prestigious is because we
have brought back something that has
come I've been requested so many times I
can't even count on my feeders and it's
something Jackie and I used to do and it
was very funny and like we overplay
there for sure very funny a little mean
a little mean and now we've brought it
back are you ready for it
done may I present to you the Umbridge
basket so for those some of our new
listeners
you know it was it was hard for us
because we speak a lot about people that
we just despise you know right and looks
like this is my show I create it I work
it we fund it it's like why am i
spending this show talking about people
that I [ __ ] hate so we've decided to
start baskets of people like we will no
longer discuss these people so in case
you can't see right over here it's very
similar it like under umbrage see China
you know these are people who have
either been China people who have
wronged us or people we love and it's
just people I'm not interested in
furthering their fame anymore yeah
first up tristin third-trimester
Thompson next up and they don't really
have an explanation like obviously hate
trusting cuz he cheated on Chloe when
she was pregnant no and then also just
like this stories that kept ensuing and
I was just really taking over the
dialogue and we weren't here for it next
up I don't really particularly have a
reason for the hatred of this next
person Jakob start aureus I'm gonna get
your familiar actually I do have two
reasons you I know you didn't but first
is he's 12 years old and he beat me for
our People's Choice Award two years ago
and like it's just upsetting
that's one reason to lose to a 12 year
old the other is just the way that he
makes me feel when I watch his videos
because he's like I said 12 and he's
sexualizing himself like rubbing his
hair and licking his lips in his
musically videos and in case you haven't
seen it it goes a little something like
this
look he literally just post videos like
that like to like have other 12 year old
girls thinks he think he's hot and like
honesty I'm just not here for the
sexualization of children and the thirst
monstering of Jacob Sartorius and yes
I'm still a little better than he beat
me for the People's Choice Awards so
there's that next up we have blac Chyna
who as you guys with Mowgli know she was
inspiration behind the phrase Chyna Inc
which means to completely get rid of an
ex someone out and for so many reasons
is she in this basket but most acutely
known for showing us her vagina before
noon the vagina the China gate finally
for like I don't even need to explain
why Nick avail is a Nerium is really the
inspiration for this basket I just
[ __ ] hate him and I don't think I
need a reason I don't think you do but
if I didn't need a reason it would be
that he asked Andi Dorfman on live
television why she had sex with him if
he didn't if she didn't let me know and
then proceeded to be on three more shows
and like not understand that we don't
want to see you anymore next basket is
something that it's more of a passion
project I would say yeah this is really
Pat I feel strongly I'm sorry that
everyone's heads are different
dimensions I just I did it very last
minute so this is what we like to call
the
this basket and it includes people who
you know need justice that's why we have
our custom gavels get ready yep sorry
that's really why we started this show
it's like a platform for justice and
even though our current setup doesn't
really you know allow for that kind of
you know banging it's still it still is
real it's in our heart so this has
really been updated since the toast got
got its start because there's so many
people new people that we really find we
need justice for first and foremost one
Meredith Blake if you don't know where
she is a stepmom soon-to-be stepmom in
The Parent Trap and I just feel like she
was wrong I think she was wrong like she
was in a relationship and then like not
only does this confirm come home from
camp then she has a twin with the
ex-wife and it's it's a lot of drama
also it's lizard in her backpack she's
26 years old and like she's trying to
marry into the vineyard lifestyle I
couldn't agree more
how can you hate it I like I choose a
publicist on it so she works she should
have been Forbes 30 under 30 but I'm
sure that she was like in her full-time
resume her LinkedIn definitely had a
link to her Forbes 30 under 30 and like
we should be supporting women in
business we are women who support other
women I Meredith Lake is one of and by
the way they put a salamander like on
her water bottle and pushed her into the
lake like and rocks in her backpack
that's literally my worst nightmare that
is just like sleeping on the lake what
she gets motion sick terrible that's not
cool
next up I think this might be our most
important work and that's why her head
is the biggest also because it was the
only picture I could find one Sharpay
Evans
yeah like Sharpay Evans
I don't even I'm gonna just funny how as
an adult you see things differently
right I'm gonna give you the elevator
pitch of why we are serving up dresses
first Sharpay first of all High School
Musical one she's worked her whole life
to be in the musical these two hacks
come in and not only like are they not
like prepared really but they're not
even gonna give the musical they're all
they have all these other passion prizes
are not following the rules you're not
allowed to be multiple extracurriculars
right like I had to choose between Ford
hockey and soccer like you have to
choose between basketball and the
theater and we all know that basketball
is more important to Troy Bolton
right even though it was his dad's dream
and he had to get his head in the game
you gotta gotta get your head in the
game
so like of Cordon Bleu they met his
feelings she's been working like for
years because of how much money her
family has invested in her career dance
lessons tap lessons tap shoes for these
to pee stink lessons like come on who
just stumbled into the theater ran in
heist
musical - okay so she has a crush on
Troy and by the way she wants to help
him buddy back back to number one when
it comes to auditions and when it comes
to the theater all of that is irrelevant
it's really based on talent talent wise
Gabriela was no Sharpay let's just get
that straight
just because Sharpay staying more like
papi papi songs were supposed to think
that she's worse she was the real towel
no they're both talented I think Sharpay
was a little like more theatrical
whereas Gabriella was a little more like
in Fiona Apple totally so it's like when
you're producing a musical as the spring
musicale as miss darbus would say it's
all about the actuality I completely
agree High School Musical - all she's
trying to do is help Troy I like move up
oh and by she she had a crush on him
she's had a crush on him all throughout
high school and middle school presumably
and then this girl just walks in and
they met on vacation I'm like steals her
love I would hate Gabriella to like come
on guys stick to the status quo okay
next up next up is something really I
would say important to us for on a
personal level I would say even more so
than sharp a B could be - like the love
that we have for this man yeah and I
feel like I wake up every day thinking
how can I find justice for best on today
and I haven't found a way yet but I just
think it's really important that
everyone rewatch not the original the
most recent Beauty and the Beast and
watch it through the lens of like maybe
Gaston isn't such a bad guy and then
you'll see like Belle was so mean to him
like there's a way to by the way all he
wanted to do was ruin Mary Belle right
ruin Mary Belle all he wanted to do was
ruin Mary Belle and I get that she's not
interested but he never like he never
touched her like inappropriately like
she was acting like he was the
patriarchy and like and and I didn't
like how disrespectful she was there's a
way to reject someone and like he put
his feelings out there he was really
vulnerable and she was super rude back
right and her chicken coop
technically liked him leading Maurice in
the woods was like not cool no not
Maurice is so goddamn annoying
I would totally really like then you
know he really loses his mind when he
tries to kill the Beast from behind kill
the Beast
but like he's gone crazy at that point
okay so I just agree with you there what
do you lose Marius in the woods
understandable for sure but also like
like would you want to be on a road
nobody okay sometimes people just snap
like D'Andra
we'll talk about the houses announced at
the end by sometimes like people push
you to the breaking point and you do the
wrong thing but like they pushed you
there I just want to say Belle's family
being so me to Gaston they pushed him
there and I don't agree what he did to
Maurice wasn't nice but also like him
wanting to kill a beast to trying to
take over the village like who Luke held
a woman captive like technically like
brainwashed chair Stockholm Syndrome
which is some theories I don't like
subscribe to that but the beast wasn't a
great guy like he took Maurice hostage
do you know also understand from
stealing a rose by the way right and
then also talk about your Matta and then
also took the Bell hostage and then like
only let her out cuz she was a pretty
girl like the Bell let me know isn't
this great catch you know so I really
feel like if you watch the movie through
that lens you might be persuaded agreed
also the only way that justice for
Gaston can be served up on a steaming
hot platter is if they do a Gaston
clearance story wicked style musical
where we see where Gaston comes from he
came from the war maybe has a little
PTSD right and Jackie was the one who
explained that it's set in a certain
time period in France and actually after
the movie ends is when the French
Revolution starts going to happen so all
the princes and the castles are gonna be
the Krauts and you know the the working
men war heroes are gonna come up the
governor so really guests on these the
Yap term capture so anyways I don't know
who are some famous musical writers
Hammerstein wants to write up a musical
back Bach I will be their first row
cheering him a long time Stephen
Sondheim would be perfect Lloyd Webber
Gershwin Gershwin Barrymore I don't that
I don't know drew Barrymore simply I was
anyway I think it's a brilliant again
for a while I was like maybe I shouldn't
put out the universe because someone
will inevitably copy it but now I'm
hoping someone does because I just don't
have the bandwidth to write amis no but
I will take on the role of like guest
stones mother Oh first sister yeah and
I'll take on their roller just like a
neighbor Altima Bonjour you know oh my
god it's crazy
and then finally probably this one is
most deep rooted in history and the
reason why we started this basket of
justice is a little man named David
Foster for a while I mean how do you
know David Foster his name like when was
the first time you heard of him was it
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills
piano right with this innate fat okay
yeah that's what swim team what's the
same a baby fat yeah no yeah right baby
Thanks see this I was like that basis
okay so I mean I really feel like
justice actually has been served for
David Foster if you could click your o
because not only is he in what appears
to be a very loving relationship in
which his family has embraced he's also
friends with girl with no job so like
he's really all set he's killing it he's
got everything he needs for a while he
got a bad rap because I'm real how's his
Beverly Hills it would seem that he
married go on she got sick he bounced
and I do think that they're much like a
stone there's a lot more to the story
right and I really feel like he wanted
to be excluded from the narrative in
which he never asked to be a part of
right and you know he sends so much
great work for music that I can look
past just a couple passes I am just like
so glad we brought the baskets back I
just felt like we are like we have
returned we have returned
yeah and it was nice to just go through
all the all of our passion projects of
yeah you're on the air winded between
that and the note right we have so much
to talk about today I hope you have time
I do buy flights at two from LaGuardia
oh you're cool so we're chillin and it's
a [ __ ] pack to ask flight because
there's apparently some basketball game
in Alabama like the championships Rose
Bowl no Rose hood um anyways we have a
lot of TV to discuss because I did spend
my day yesterday catching up on some
some research so did I and I don't want
to catch up on like a bunch of episodes
of random shows I said I'm gonna do my
own did anything a day yesterday I did
Real Housewives of Dallas and I am in
complete agreement with you and like you
always say like I wish you almost didn't
like taint me uh-huh
because I'm like Jackie doesn't agree
with anyone and that was like my mind
said like maybe I would have taken a
nice hard side but I don't really feel
like I can argue on anyone's behalf
because to me everyone is wrong agreed
except for Stephanie okay and I said
this to on the phone last night
Stephanie is on track to becoming one of
the greatest housewives of all time like
from a lifestyle standpoint personality
standpoint self-awareness just drawn
openness drama way that she engages with
the women like I think she is definitely
I know DeAndre and Leeanne fried about
being the queen of the show Stephanie is
the queen of the show um and I love her
so much in the season has made me love
her even even more I completely agree
and I don't know if you agree with me on
this but like my heart like I'm like
I like feel for Deandra and that's like
she reminds me of Gaston in the sense
that like she especially when she like
lashed out and put her finger in Leon's
face and then like LeAnn shoved her like
she was out of control and you could see
in her face like she snapped and she was
pissed too that she snapped and I felt
so bad for her because she was really
pushed to that like when LeAnn was
yapping in the back well she's just
trying to try to have a conversation
with Cameron like a serious conversation
and LeAnn Gabby like I would have
[ __ ] snap too and I could just see in
the moment the second she snapped and
then knew that she snapped and like
tried to reel it back and I felt really
bad for her it's not an excuse for bad
behavior but like you she was provoked
definitely and also like I feel like all
seasoned people are trying to get LeAnn
to snap but LeAnn has a fuse this big
like that is true I am person who's
capable of snapping but my fuse is this
long and I feel like the answer is in
the same way so yes we can all get to
this point it's not like oh she off to
that point that means something like
right it's like no then you just did
this amount of pushing and I identify
with LeAnn in the sense that my fuse is
this like I will react like it's the end
of the world after to calm like I really
can't be controlled so I do I am
impressed with Leon's restraint this
season because people have been testing
her kind of wanting her to like be the
bad guy that she usually is and she
hasn't given in and she's like weirdly
gave it in the last episode with try me
and I didn't know like what was going on
but she was giving and she was being the
Oh Leon while also saying I'm the newly
end yeah it's like you're do you say
that I clone your phone which is the
whole episode we've just got to get in a
millennial in there to let them know
it's not a thing I go that first that
they meant airdrop and I was like oh
okay okay but then no they meant like
hack they should have been saying hack
but like they don't know and they were
like clone and I was what the [ __ ] is
these ladies talking about no it was so
funny but I do think that the like
impetus behind not impetus like the
motivation behind Leeanne saying that
was like so mean she was like I just
wanted to scare her yeah and like a bike
that someone hacked my phone and like
I'm sure Brandi has like pictures of
like her naked or like them drinking
like I just a text message you get when
you're looking at like you just I mean
my phone I would die like literally die
yeah so I don't know I thought that was
really really mean and then she owned
like the reason why I did it was like I
want to skip rent I wanted to get back
at you
like that's old leanne with new with new
tricks that she has new weapons but it's
still the same person do you think so I
don't think like I have I take umbrage
with this ugly and new Leon thing no
bumpers with that formula in housewives
me don't you Vinita - Ramona right like
I have to become a new I'm a new person
now and if I do if I'm up to my old ways
like no you are the same person
for better or for worse as you should be
you are who you are at Leon you're
40-something years old you've lived your
whole life this way what all of a sudden
you change because of a seats not
housewives I don't think that's real nor
should it be me people shouldn't be
demanding her to be a new person either
you like her for who she is
I've totally a good and bad or you don't
feel like I'm so tired of this like oh
she went back to old no she's new
if she did this is only add like that's
how we like measure how we feel about
her I agree do you think Brandi took
brandi stole Nan's phone no I think
Brandi found Leanne's phone on her way
up to returning it tried to get into it
and make sure the pictures were deleted
realized she couldn't and just return it
stay because then I was thinking first
of all where she needs two hours with a
phone that she can't get it not only
that if you're gonna like steal
someone's phone and then want to make it
seem like you're not the person who
stole it like it just went missing you
don't take two hours like you take five
seconds you get all your information and
then you run or at least that's what I
would do and like you mentioned
yesterday I want to be the person to
return it cuz I would make you look
guilty like I found your phone I would
have someone else ooh and brings
different yet also they look they like
said they briefly mentioned that the
phone was found between the cushions
which is a very real thing that happens
that's the only time I've ever really
lost my phone for long periods of time
and not know where it was it it's
between the kitchen your house yeah
totally totally totally and wait oh and
I need to talk about the camera in lien
dynamics yes and I don't I was trying to
watch through your lens I don't agree
with you really at all when it comes to
Cameron I still find her just as
annoying and by the way when I was
cutting out pictures of Sharpay like uh
Cameron is sharp a totally you find her
just as annoying as I season um like the
same I don't think she's changed at all
I find like her blind defect like you
can be something this is what's wrong
with the Housewives
you can be someone's friend but also
tell them like what they did wasn't cool
it's like you have to take a side and
defend them it's like if you're my
friend and you did something crazy I be
like [ __ ] you're being crazy like that
should be nice for everyone while the
craziness is happening or beauty once
right so I
like she's done that no she really liked
any any time Lance uh Simon Cameron's
like yeah I agree he's so good to
everyone
so yeah that's true she was like I think
Brandi stole the phone he's not saying
yeah I agree
well sometimes she's saying I agree but
she's also just going like this like
she's listening to everyone and I don't
think she realized that she seems like
she's agreeing yeah but she thinks that
she looks like she's listening right but
when you're going like this that's
technically a nod oh that's true you
know I don't know I just don't feel the
way you feel about her at all I think
she's like I get that she comes from an
impressive family and that not even
sorry she married into an important
family and much she who wears the crown
and wears ooh well I just don't like her
like at all
I she's really starting to it I never
said that like I love her I'm just
saying I'm starting to understand who
she is a little bit more and I don't
think she's change from last season but
now I just understand why she does what
she does a little bit more sure but I
think it can really be boiled down to
like the season is so long that you
forget what happens like when they went
to her ski lodge yeah and the whole baby
adoption thing like that to me was the
most outrageous argument anyone could
ever make and for her sake at the
Reunion I hope she just apologizes and
if she continues to defend that line
which was like you didn't tell me
like I will die like that was so
outrageous yes it was outrageous but
then towards the end of the season you
see that kam and Brandi have a real
friend yes yes so maybe like she should
have known I wonder how many people
really did know and she seems really
sensitive like I just even people make
other people's like whether it's like a
a moment of joy or like a sadness about
them like that pisses me off that shows
a lack of self-awareness and being
really self-centered and I just like
hated everything about that regardless
of this she was justified but I don't
think she was I hate that I totally
agree and I feel like I'm sitting here
at defending Cameron when she's not even
who I stand I'm just I don't know who I
stab I think that's Sandhya I stand
Deandra and I stand Stephanie so like
wherever sent you those I go I feel
first and this is what I feel like is
going on Stephanie is giving Leeanne a
chance
I don't know that they're ever gonna be
the best of friends but Sevigny realizes
that this is a show and ever it's it's
like an orchestra and all the music and
the instrument having to play it
together so even if she thinks Leeanne
is crazy in the back of her mind
she's gonna just push that aside and and
film hmm Brandi on the other hand like
he's out of the game she's sitting at
the table she's saying like everyone
here is being steak as [ __ ] like yeah
they are because there
coworkers I'm Abby Smith day with my
coworkers all the time yeah I don't know
you guys I'm one of my co-workers every
day we want to have lunch with you right
here I am having lunch I drink because
we're getting paid to be here so I think
Stephanie understand that and brandy
it's like I feel like maybe I just feel
like her heart's not in it no I do think
though that at in any hood housewives
cast there has to be people on all sides
there have to be people who coexist
otherwise the group will never hang out
together yes but there also there has to
be the outliers like the people who
everyone hates or hates everyone that's
how it works and then those people
eventually get fit fizzles out but that
is how like the the the housewives are
Mila no no with an A Dynamis fear like
climate something like that what I was
in whether word that's how it works okay
but I don't want Brandi to take it too
far and I think she really like III like
Stan her and I used to like love her but
like she was being a little crazy at the
frat party which looked so fun it looked
so fun I actually didn't think she was
being crazy yet she was different you
know what she was definitely trying to
push Liam yes I thought she was being
more so not crazy because I understood
where she was coming from but irrational
and like not playing the game at that
dinner in Copenhagen where she was just
like you're all being [ __ ] fake I
think she just wanted to walk out and
like have a moment that like they could
use in all the promo
perhaps but yes she's like going to the
point of no-return over something that's
pretty benign whereas like you saved
that moment of like it's me or her for
when Vicki calls Kelly a coke addict on
the reunion okay Kelly's not coming back
to the OC unless Vicki leaves because
she said that team Kelly oh my god all
the way Vicki is an animal okay I'll
catch up on that next because that
sounds good okay you want to get into
the stories I guess we can jump into the
Fast Five story is that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast speaking and
packing up on TV ariana grande shares
heartbreaking letter on manchester
bombing in new docu-series in her new
docu-series in an emotional letter to
fans ariana grande opens up about her
feelings about what she calls the
horrendous 2017 suicide bombing at her
Manchester concert grande announced on
social media earlier this week that the
biographical project titled dangerous
woman diaries has been produced and will
begin airing on 3rd
day four episodes were released on
YouTube and I watched all of them how
long are they um probably an hour each
yeah it felt like an hour okay in the
fourth one grande displays a letter she
penned to her fans about the Manchester
terrorist attack which killed 22 people
and injured at least 500 others quote
I'm writing to you the stubby arene it's
been eight months since the attack at
our show at the Manchester Arena it's
possible to know where to start or know
what to say about this part may 22nd
2017 will leave me speechless and filled
with questions for the rest of my life
music is an escape music is the safest
thing I've ever known music pop music
stand culture is something that brings
people together introduces them to some
of their best friends and makes them
feel like they can be themselves it is
comfort it is fun it is expression it is
happiness it is the last thing that
would ever harm someone it is safe when
something so opposite and so poisonous
takes place in your world that is
supposed to be everything but that it is
shocking and heartbreaking in a way that
seems impossible to fully recover from
so wow that's really real win well
written and I'm just like never cease
females by ariana grande look I just
love her no I love her there was even
more about like the spirit of the people
of Manchester and their families have
like what got her through it and like
showed her how amazing humanity can be
so I watched this document and something
that I thought was it so the first
episode is all about like sweetener
stuff and like doing music videos and
putting out the album and then goes into
dangerous woman Diaries which they never
intended to make and was just footage
from the tour that they had because her
buddy was just killing everything and
then I'm sure like YouTube offered them
a deal and they cost us just together
they cobbled together this footage and
they're very open about it like her hair
is literally different in every scene
and it's really cute and sweet it's
basically just the concert with like her
notes like any sort of concert DVD oh so
it's like a it's a whole show oh nice I
hate her like I want to down like kind
of like the Hannah Montana right so
that's the both girls it's not five foot
two okay you know so it's it's it's
really cute she's just such a cutie and
it's really crazy how like her spirit at
the beginning of the tour and she
literally says in their huddle before
the first show like I just want to make
people feel good and feel safe
especially when they leave here to just
like take that with them and like it's
so like I ramas that
ominous that that the bombing happened
as they left a concert like she
literally said I want them to feel safe
when they leave here and those sad
attacked opposite happened in like her
spirit at the beginning of the show
she's like bopping around like she has
so much Katya there's so much energy and
she's actually really funny and then the
attack happens and then like the rest of
the show is just like so heavy for them
and she was saying like on their last
tour date she was like for so long I
just wanted this to go by I wanted to be
done with it now that it's here it's
like it's just so sad this tour has
meant like so much just so many people I
love her so much I feel like there's a
like I mean not that there's any
precedent for like how a celebrity
should handle something like this but if
there was it should be our honor grande
like she is just a pillar of elegance
and class and positivity and positivity
and hope and I did not like that Piers
Morgan came for it came for her but he
apologized he apologized
I just feel like Pierce Morgan it's like
always saying crazy things like
sometimes I greeted that like sometimes
it out right and it's like even though
he apologized I'm sure Ariana read it at
like the worst time in her life and like
I'm sure it made her feel ten times
worse and I don't think she'll ever
forget him
and she shouldn't because it was so
terrible right and who was the one like
it was like when Kim was robbed and
someone suggested that like Bette Midler
no and I think it was like Howard Stern
said something like she organized oh
wait when Kim was robbed I'm talking
about when Kim was naked
oh no when Kim was robbed someone like
suggested that it was like in the inside
yeah I don't think it's Howard Stern
okay maybe it was Piers Morgan then I
don't know and I just feel like I'll
never I wait if I were them I would
never forget that I'm gonna say
something crazy I've never in my life
because I've never had a serious XM
channel I've never heard Howard Stern
interview I've never listened to his
show I've literally never seen his work
other than being a judge on America's
Got Talent for one season but I Stan
Howard Stern I said I don't see why I've
seen specific interviews he asks the
important questions and like in a very
nonchalant way right he's just like a
great host and an interesting I feel
like you would like us I can't explain
no I feel like we have a female Howard
Stern vibe going on oh for sure
Fresno right just like I'm gonna put it
on the universe like I like Howard Stern
I like him too and I don't know him and
I don't know why it's like I really
don't know anything about her I know his
wife does really an ayzik work for
animals and she's like so beautiful I
was always going to watch ovens live but
like I really don't know anything about
Howard Stern I just know
like makes so much money yet and he's
just a reverent and doesn't give a [ __ ]
yeah and he's respected by everyone
regardless of if they agree with him or
not I'm here for it also I was watching
documentary and like she is literally
the most beautiful person in the world
and it's so crazy I was hoping we would
get at least one shot of her like
straight out the shower wet hair no
makeup that did not happen by the night
would you had a documentary would you
yes like I would love to see her without
with wet hair and makeup like you know
cuz she is always in costume also what
is her natural hair I do not because
even when she was a kid that color
wasn't her natural hair no I don't know
I think it's like up to here and it
looks like all slicked back now like
it's just like I don't think she has
much of it I think what's on her scalp
and like up till here is hers and the
rest is Pony you know I'm not interested
in seeing her without makeup I'm seeing
I'm interested in seeing her hair
what is her hair I don't know she's in
that pony all the time she said the
nerves in her scalp have just given up
she's to get headaches from the pony and
like now she doesn't it's so tight it's
so it was hurting my neck watching her
my round and also like she whips her
neck and it's heavy and her frame is so
small and fro I don't get it it's
honestly it goes against physics mhm
that the proportions we have like got to
take this thing down it's from your
birthday to take horror oh but I nodded
it so like for another time well just
have to cut it um anyways I recommend
watching it but you do have to pay for
it I have you TV YouTube YouTube TV and
it came in handy just YouTube premium
count yes okay that's what you have to
have okay I thought maybe you two TB
didn't even get me and I was gonna be
pissed like what the [ __ ] am I paying
for its whole so YouTube like we love
you here we are on YouTube but you've
got to streamline everything between
YouTube YouTube originals YouTube
premium YouTube read what the [ __ ] am i
watching I just need it like this
I need youtube free and YouTube plus
also like in your app you just need to
have a thing where like save video it's
just so annoying like when I'm trying to
post premium content to the chest
Instagram apps download like seven
million like shady-ass who taught apps
to get it apparently it's annoying
totally
anyways if you want to come over and
watch the dangerous woman die well maybe
you can come to my house since I now
have a home oh and play with a VHS oh by
the way I didn't need to tell you are
you free to take nephew so just like two
hours today I'm always free but can you
do it at my apartment yes yeah
but no but and you'll see like I've
really made a wonderful home for my
family I'm excited to see because I
cooked for the first action oh I didn't
cook me and been ordered in and I put it
on glass plates which really made me
feel like I cooked but can you cook for
your friends the other night no I mean I
made rice and then I also ordered it I
just placed I was ordering in from
didn't have rice you're obsessed with
rice I'm obsessed with rice and it's
hard for me because I just refused I
mean I hate cooking for so many reasons
mostly dishes but also been loves to
cook like for a snack he'll just like
flip up a frittata and it's so [ __ ]
annoying because he doesn't even use the
dishes and it's like he's like I'll do
it I'll do it but then the crusty cheese
on the pans and it's like our pans get
ruined in ten seconds and it's so
annoying and it literally he knows like
he's not allowed to cook anymore but I
got new pans that are truly like you
know how do you make you see like a
infomercial from Barcelona it's like the
cheese slides right off and it's like
baked I got those they're made of
granite
they're emceeing they're made of granite
and literally the cheese slides right
off
it's a crazy saying Bentley's a crusty
ketchup on everything it's so long now
Ben is allowed to cook like one so
because I will scrub that dish because
it takes two seconds that's incredible
yeah also my new year's resolution for
2018 was to learn how to cook it hasn't
happened quite yet but I got these pans
too and now I feel inspired because I
have nothing against cooking but I have
some take some umbrage with dishes like
yesterday of course food is delicious
takes 10 seconds to eat three days to do
the dishes right so they are nonstick
and no oil or butter is needed to use
these pans which makes it also healthier
but I still use butter unless you're on
keto in which case it doesn't matter but
anyways to get your own nonstick grana
crock pots and pans go to smart over
comm and use the coupon code toast TOA
st for 20% off your entire order this
deal will only last three days you guys
so act fast smart over comm SMA RT o VA
dot-com for like non-stick pans that
literally are like an infomercial I feel
like the OxiClean I know and like I feel
like I know it's an ad for sure but like
I use it and I can't even tell you like
the granite I don't know what the [ __ ]
it's made of and it looks it does if
they look physically different than my
actual pans they have like little white
dots in it and Ben is like over a joy
because he can make like one omelette a
week now know it gives me like Fred
Flinstone vibes like how he used to cook
granite the classics the classics doing
it like the caveman totally I love Fred
Flintstone me - he was like a catch no
totally okay
next story I know that we're not talking
about them but Priyanka Chopra is on the
cover of Vogue America yeah December
issue the covers coming out in December
okay but I'm some Tibbets released from
do you think she'll wear a wedding dress
I think so like now I understand why
whatever they're doing like it is it's
working she she wouldn't be vogue she
would never have even been considered to
be great especially now that her show is
over I'm so like a maybe in the Quantico
days she would have been on the cover of
Oh baby it didn't happen and now
marrying a Jonas gets you on the cover
of Vogue so here she is they tease some
details from the interview apparently
Nick Jonas slid into her DMS and that is
how they went out but by the way since
it's all like a fake relationship the
story of how they met is also like a
create a manipulated straight but it's
not it's not that they do you think eg
I'm sure like hey what a fake get
married so we could both become more
famous and you could finally get on the
cover of Vogue and maybe my solo career
will finally take off sure Nick that
sounds awesome I'll meet you in Mumbai
Mike so here's the story make like
Priyanka Chopra grab your bikini Bellini
and a seat by the pool because this is a
story worth sitting down for who wrote
this who needs to be shot of course it's
the bright maybe they're getting paid
like ala least I hope it said that
hashtag ad at the end as a bride to be
revealed to go but it's called editorial
oh yeah as the bride to be revealed to
vote for her January 2019 cover
interview quote bikini Bellinis make me
[ __ ] it's my happy place it's one of the
many revelations that's really shocking
she and her future husband pop superstar
Hermes loosely do you know what the word
revelation means do you know the term
Superstar means well no she is our pop
superstar Nick don't
oh no no first bounce our superstar no
pop star
no not even singer he's a pop star he
allowed us he's a singer he's not a
superstar he's not a pop star he's a
singer okay pop stars where the
microphones around there do you know
what he was in the Jonas Brothers and
like they were pop today we're
superstars yeah more pop superstar okay
curry thirst monster right day bones to
the max mr. Chopra ahead of they're a
highly innovative
this weekend when their engagement was
confirmed just four short months ago in
mid-july the couple had blindsided
Hollywood after all they had brushed off
any rumor of romance after attending the
2017 Met Gala together as gala guests of
Ralph Lauren plus AZ Chopra acknowledged
to the magazine she kept any and all
signs of her relationship out of the
spotlight quote I've had that will my
whole life she told Vogue never publicly
acknowledged our relationship ever I
understand that and I also understand
publicly acknowledging a relationship
but what you're doing is such a far cry
brainer but that's always been my mantra
but I decided this year to do the exact
opposite is that how she finishes
sentence but that's the only way I would
make sense
however the beginnings of a lifelong
love was taking shape in a very modern
place her Twitter direct messages that's
right Joey still a Twitter into her
d-ends but it wasn't entirely suave as
the story goes Nick Jonas first texted
you mean message the actress Quantic
like killed so he texted the actresses
co-star Graham Rogers and said Priyanka
is Wow as he assured the magazine that's
not the way I talk then but you said it
quote I'm hearing from a few mutual
friends that we should meet he wrote to
her she responded day up with a message
that said my team could read this why
don't you just text me Oh cuz I guess
everyone has access to her Twitter text
they did for five more months until they
ran into each other in February 2017 at
the Vanity Fair Oscar party there Jonas
made a grand gesture worthy of a Julia
Roberts rom-com okay I can't read this
probably Sarah but like truly like a
mother spent a bad joke I really like an
inglorious basterds when they were
playing that propaganda it's this know
this is true propaganda also I'm hearing
from a few mutual friends I'll you
should meet you mean like publicist
right no Hollywood is so fake and so
like contrived this is the dumbest story
ever article is not really the boat
quotes but the narrative he the e
cushioning of the language like Jackie
you know there are some people who like
walk around this earth just thinking
that like Selena Gomez except for some
anxiety and that's why she's in rehab
and not it's because she's addicted to
drugs yeah there are also people who
walk this earth believing this trash
like oh my god I want some day to grow
up and have a marriage like Nick and
Bianca modern fairytale like there are
people who think that and like for those
people I am sad oh my god I want to read
the vogue interview I want to hear it
from nobody I will be purchasing this
edition right but like I'm sorry
you've taken it way too far it's almost
as if emos this is a joke and they're
just putting in the being satirical
right this is satire this is satirical
this is two-tier if I've ever heard
however speaking of real true love
Luke combs is engaged to girlfriend
Nicole Hocking okay for so many reasons
and I overcome with joy one I like know
them and like I think I have like a 1%
yeah we have like a 1% chance of getting
event to the wedding depending on how
big it is like if they're trying to be
like thirsty pres right you know it's
really depending on how big it is yes
we're not even thirsty Nora we press
we're friends we're friends were friends
um like I'm so happy for that reason
second of all like I just think Luke
Combs is really gonna be like the next
Garth Brooks and to know that he has
like a happy home makes it all even
better like he found his Trisha Yearwood
you know I'm his Trisha Yearwood and she
is a toaster meaning that she is in tune
with what's necessary she quality go in
all facets of life all and so she she's
funny oh and she's beautiful she's great
taste she has great taste in in culture
and it's so cute because apparently
they've been engaged for quite some time
he did it in the kitchen which is just
like the most looms thing I've ever
heard which is also very hairy and Megan
yes
he did in the kitchen and they didn't
tell anyone and then they're in Bahamas
for the BMI awards or the BMI retreat or
whatever and they have like an official
photo shoot and they thought it would be
like a better a cuter place to announce
and like I appreciate and they were
right
they were right but I have to say I
think each at the CMAs I think were they
lying to your girl I think well we never
had a chance to talk to them off camera
so many and it's not like I specifically
said are you engaged and she lied to my
face you know right but it's like they
knew and they knew how happy wouldn't
guess but they couldn't tell us because
everything was live yeah we had seen
them backstage I'm sure they would have
spent me and another reason why I'm just
like so overcome with joy is because I
think everyone needs to follow her on
Instagram because she does amazing
behind the scenes of Luke combs like I
feel like if I was just a regular
consumer who didn't know Luke comes I go
just get like his Instagram and his
concerts this guy wears his fishing sure
he's very like on brand with himself but
you don't know how on brand he is with
himself until you see him at home he was
in the hotel lobby yesterday wearing a
t-shirt with the kid food salad on it
and camo Crocs
and Nico Hocking was zooming in on his
crops and then like all these all of his
friends came and they were all wearing
Crocs like she was like it's a croc
athan in the lobby it was so funny like
her Instagram is so good because you see
she did business combs on the play and
he was like on his tablet like he was so
mad I know I'm so happy for them and you
know what this also means like more
music of course and now it's all the
songs that are on this album are like
old song say they wrote in college and
has been writing his whole life like now
we're gonna get engagement songs we're
gonna get half like rock out with your
[ __ ] out songs yeah and go find a wife I
saw a funny meme today
music sad ice until who comes happy
listen to Luke Kim's heartbroken listen
to Luke comes in love listen to Luke
comes driving on a back road listen to
the hums three I am listen to Luke comes
hey great today listen to it comes I
listen to what I hear he I'm so happy
for them
I'm so happy I feel like a part of it a
liitle part of it
little anyways how long have they been
together like a couple two years they
said on um cm a red carpet oh wow I
don't in the morning toast and Access
Hollywood czar there you were there okay
um okay next story cuz we have six I'm
just breathing through them dj khaled
employ me whether junior are charged
with cryptocurrency fraud floating with
Oh junior is that the regular floating
me mother yes yes I believe so
yep music producer DJ Colin and boxer
Floyd Mayweather jr. were charged by
this SEC Thursday with promoting
investments in initial cryptocurrency
coin offerings without revealing that
they'd been paid the SEC has said that
cryptocurrency coin sold in initial coin
offerings may be considered securities
and subject to federal securities laws
both Khaleda Mayweather settled with the
SEC and agreed not to promote any
securities even digital ones for two
years and three years respectively they
also agreed to give back the money they
received to the SEC SEC and pay
penalties with interest damn I just have
to say like I do not [ __ ] with Floyd
Mayweather at all like I am ready for
the coming of the what's where we use
for the Savannah from the reckoning of
Floyd Mayweather Mayweather like I
despise him and if you like not I feel
like you've been talking about him like
I'm gonna get in trouble like he is the
worst the money team is coming for you
also what's so crazy is his business and
ours have the same initial to Mt TMT so
we were I think we were looking up like
if we could trade market like we can no
but I don't think anyone can you
shouldn't be able to trademark initials
it was like what if my name was Tamara
Morey TIA
right and then here like exact toast
know for sure but like I don't [ __ ] with
Floyd Mayweather at all like what he did
to that female reporter that she was
only person to
a real question about what happened the
domestic violence saying and she was
never allowed back I don't [ __ ] with
Floyd Mayweather he's in my basket of
China like I don't like him at all and I
don't want something I don't want to
talk about not liking him because I'm
scared of money to know for sure but
like anytime he's in a fight like I'm
secretly rooting for the other person
even though like I don't totally but I'm
always rooting for the underdog not even
for the underdog but for the people
who's placed bets on the other dog who
are gonna get paid out huge yeah like I
was fully on manny pacquiao side and
then he turned out to be like a crazy
homophobe
no I was fully on Conor McGregor
suddenly - until it turned out that he
wasn't even the same league as Floyd
Mayweather and they shouldn't have even
been fighting together and by the way
they were and they played different
sports and Conor I just found this out
after not enough people were talking
about this because flood another Floyd
Mayweather controls media he contributed
by different sports but Conor was
playing at Floyd - sport of course Floyd
won right I would like to see Floyd in
Connors but when I found that out and
that there's really like there wasn't a
shot in hell that Connor was gonna win
like then I didn't launch also justice
for like the revelation me having
watched eyes glued to the teachers just
for Ronda Rousey always she sucks no she
really got ahead of her she was a fall
from grace if I've ever seen she's in
the WWE now that's not even real right
and that's what I need to happen to
Floyd Mayweather meet you I'm like I
really don't [ __ ] with Floyd Mayweather
like at all except speaking of
cryptocurrency I was watching shark tank
I'm really catching up because um all I
can think about is giving me like so
many things I want to catch up on on the
plane I don't watch dangerous woman
Shark Tank or I already have shots at
sunset download it um dangerous woman
just because of the pertinence and then
shark Cain okay but there was an app and
I can't remember if anyone invested but
it was so smart it basically like so if
you spend 50 cents on a candy on your
credit card it'll take the other cents
other 50 cents and invest it in
cryptocurrency which you don't
understand but they'll do it for you so
that seems like you're you think all
Ponzi's no but you're using spare change
to invest and it's not something that
you would have invested in I think
that's smart I just don't like the
crypto element I don't trust crypto K
but you could do that with other apps so
creative stuff yeah technology smart no
and that is smart to use your spare
change but I did finally watch the
episode last night okay by the way I've
been telling Jackie to watch not even
the episode this one pitch because the
kid who did it went to Colgate and his
pitch was and he mentioned Colgate about
three times in each time like you'd like
a Colgate an alum
it's wings right let Jackie went to
Colgate which is a very small liberal
arts it's a very technical
no okay he he that's he said you play
basketball and he was always traveling
and in the airport and on the bus her
basketball so that's probably why we
didn't cross paths okay and at first I
was like loving his entrepreneurial vibe
I'm like a Colgate alum like you get it
young millennial out with his mom him
with his mom I was like I [ __ ] love
this guy and when he said Colgate I was
like oh my god he's the guy this is the
guy he was not the guy
it was the most atrocious his a black
vote trippy it actually goes down I was
looking to see what episode of West I
could watch it and it had gone down like
amongst like reddit Shark Tank viewers
as the worst pitch of all time because
not only was the product so terrible it
didn't solve a problem and actually
cater to nobody the pitch subsequently
was even worse and his attitude was
terrible there we entitlement like the
The Crying the Marino the choking the
throw I can't he threw his tuna sandwich
because he said you could like now gonna
burrito if you know where things are in
the air board he threw it into the trash
can after talking about being a d1
basketball player and he missed the
trash can like and then was finish the
pitch and couldn't stop to me and choked
and then let's get water and our Cuban
was like do you want to finish your
burrito
they gave him so many chances and they
also gave him ideas as they were sitting
there to make it better no cuz they were
like there really should have done when
with trippy was cuz I don't really
remember tonight it's an app that she
navigates airports we it's basically
like an airport digital map that shows
you where the what restaurants are way
Airport no it's not even ways it's it
tells you what restaurant it's a
directory to right Airport directory it
tells you what restaurants are in the
airport so you know if you need to go to
the newsstand next to you or is there a
burrito place three minute walk away
instead of having to traverse the
airport which small sounds a very very
small problem like we're in like we're
in the airport for 40 minutes like you
know what I'll have a tuna fish sandwich
and if there is a burrito over there oh
wow [ __ ] look like that is just the
essence of like glut world the Roberts
world problems thank you that's exactly
what it is so I gave you a word yes it
really no like a first first world
problem and then he met
he was like I wanted to be a like aways
for travelers where they can talk to
each other and then Laurie later on
picked up on that she was like we do
need a waist for travelers but not so
they can talk to each other he wants to
create a community for travelers I do
not want to talk to my fellow traveler
that it's like my idea of Hell
communicate my fellow traveler there
should be an app that tells you based on
traveler data like how long the TSA line
is yeah so you know how long you need to
leave for the airport what are the
initial traffic and he was like yeah
that's a good idea too like he was
getting ideas just sitting there but
then when things started to go south
which they always do in Shark Tank it's
not they weren't B and they were
actually for how immature he was they
were being very coddling and I feel like
sometimes they're too harsh on people
where is mr. underflow buddy coming out
swinging some they're so mean to some
people who are like there may not have
the best thing but they're like
hard-working and like their blood sweat
and money tears have done it and like I
think they're too hard sometimes they
took so long being so nice to this kid
who literally started crying he was like
look like literally what if they didn't
like his idea it was so crazy and I
can't believe that they weren't more
like and it had to be marketable so they
were actually really nice they all went
out he'd starts leave he comes back and
says you don't understand how hard I've
been working on this sitting in the back
of the bus doing this app coding and
finally Mark Cuban like put him in his
place but I needed it to be from mr.
wonderful feel to nice and then he goes
back out and like his hugging his mom
and crying crying no but the craziest
part was he said while he when he comes
back in in his defense but of it he was
like I pitches that Kogi and three two
three four of 30 under 30 people and
it's like I know what he's talking about
it's like a fake shark tank that they
put on at Colgate we're like people with
entrepreneurial spirit you can pitch to
real investors in like the pot is like
$10,000 and it's just like it's like a
talent show he was like I pitched this
at Colgate I was like oh my god stop
stop honestly like he that stereotype
that Millennials are entitled and like
they don't know the value of hard work
and are always looking for validation
which I feel like we are out here on the
streets combating like he just justified
the whole stereotype oh my god and the
fact that Colgate's name was sullied
like you and it's like but I have a
flight okay um okay then this will be
the fifth story actually there's two
good business stories the first idea it
was
so interesting paleis opened a fake
luxury stock store called policy to see
how much people would pay for $20 shoes
basically pay less in Santa Monica
taking over a former Armani store and
stocking it with $20 pumps and $40 boots
the chain via agency DCX growth
accelerator invited groups of
influencers to the grand opening of
policy and ask their opinions on the
design relat tal ESS I like to make it
seem like a lesbian policy partygoers
having no idea they were looking at
discount staples from the mall scene
said they pay hundreds of dollars for
the stylish shoes praising the look
materials and workmanship leather offer
for a pair six hundred and forty dollars
did they pay it or did they say they
would pay there's a big difference I say
a lot um I think I have to watch the
video but I think they said they were
they would pay it and it's all
influencers and like that's so hilarious
also this this is an amazing experiment
but not if pay less did ring up those
parts okay but they didn't keep the
money
Oh inserts got their cash back along
with free shoes their reactions caught
in the short and longer form ads those
shocked gotcha moments are fairly
priceless okay good no because this
would have been a useless experiment if
people said they would pay it if you
weren't being paid to go to an event or
you were invited by the brand you'd be
like wow what a great watch it totally
pay five dollars for it
when you definitely would not so as long
as that one actually pulled out their
credit card that I've been and this is a
brilliant social experiment it's a
brilliant social experiment and so
embarrassing for the influencers right
and I need to watch a video to see if I
recognize any of them but some of the
toaster said that they didn't know oh
okay I think was very micro Santa Monica
influencer okay I feel like I smell do
you well I have this problem we're like
I wear deodorant and perfume and like it
just doesn't stay on my body
um deodorant I agree so I've started
using just acts because it's stronger
such a good idea but then you spell like
a man sometimes but the perfume thing
doesn't stick to my skin and after
yesterday's episode where I really did
smell because I forgot deodorant and
perfume today I am lathered up in
deodorant and perfume thanks to Sanford
yeah I've been taking the sunburns with
me like in my purse because when you're
out in your hair starts to sweat your
hair smelling is the start of your whole
body so I've been like my friend Leticia
taught me spritzing my hair that's a
good place to start and you can keep it
in your purse and you can travel with it
because they send you
you choose here for smaller sizes you
choose your perfume of choice and then
they send you just really small not the
testers from the magnet nothing [ __ ]
yeah like support yeah
1,000 points for a violinist yeah like a
real thing but it's still under three
fluid ounces but it's like a legit that
would probably last me a year I would
say oh you ain't yeah but it's it's
technically it's just supposed to last
you a month until you really write
because it's a monthly it's
subscriptions for perfumes it's really
smart like I'm a big fan of it and it's
a 30 day supply that technically has 120
sprays so I guess 20 sprays how many
days are in a month 30 39 65 in a year
so it's like half a year so you should
be using four sprays at each time you
use perfume that's really smart
okay I definitely don't do that I never
know how much cheese I either use way
too much am i right you're way too
little and I stink anyways that's why I
always use semper calm to keep me right
with this exclusive offer you will get
50% off your first month today that's
only seven dollars and fifty cents for
your first perfume that scent bird scen
t-bird calm slash toasts and use our
code toast for 50% off your first month
s cen t-bird dot-com slash toasts
sign-on smell amazing
okay so we are gonna bring out our guest
who is a really popular in the toaster
community we gathered a bunch of
questions from Instagram and you guys
had some shed day better in moss salute
the ask questions and you're definitely
gonna get them trying cuz if you like
cheese tip girls it would just like do
it all so our sixth story that I just
feel like people need to know especially
if you're a star woods member is that
Marriott reveals data breach have over
five hundred million star would get wait
let's save this for when TPG comes on
the folk' but no it came out this
morning and it's actually the biggest
data breach yet and it had a lot of
sensitive information including people's
passport numbers credit card numbers so
if your Starwood member like just
doubled I feel like Mark Zuckerberg is
so relieved because like he had the
biggest data breach and now someone else
knew him who had the biggest ADA breach
Huber Yahoo seconds okay we'll take a
quick break and we'll be back with
Daniel Caroline if you have any
questions feel free to comment them on
the YouTube feed or on our Instagram
post
you
we are back with Danielle Caroline
Caroline you don't care there's no
specific specificity is that correct not
at all okay this people for Caroline
because let's do it everyone saying
Caroline but I'm like but it would've
been spelled with a Y and that's how you
guys would say it cuz like can't and
shan-dro so first I want to ask you how
you got into the toast we were just
talking about this how long you been
watching what's your favorite episode
yeah okay okay okay okay so actually I
found out about you guys this September
and I'm just so sad like I'd only been a
couple months so it's been a true one
but these have been a good a good few
months yes yeah so and I was just really
happy in you guys do like every day
because every morning I'm walking to
work in a class like that's just what I
did you're a student yeah and you're
also like YouTube Instagram famous
influencer influence or whatever it's
such like a weird word yeah like you
guys are my dream my dream as a student
like first of all you're in college
you're at going to a party every night
having the time of your you know
something cool it's like a small
community right so everyone knows
everything right gender like college
famous and then you're also like making
that influence or money for like you
know getting those bottles and it's
really nice it is really nice to people
around campus like know about you and
your work I think so it's it's so weird
cuz I'll just like be at Starbucks like
on campus like totally bumming it and
people like oh my god hey like I watch
your video it's like it's crazy she's so
funny so it is kind of nice though so
did you get your start on youtube or on
Instagram YouTube I actually started
youtube like eight years ago when like
it was like makeup tutorials I don't do
those anymore that's oh you do other
people I can't but so yeah I started
doing that and then I just did it for
fun and I just kinda like vlogs and
stuff what kind of camera do you have
like what is she filming I'm so she's
member the canon g7x for like vlogging
you guys might have seen those before
they're just kind of more simple but
then I think it goes how are you guys
can you guys please start vlogging
we do a little bit it's just we do it on
our phones oh my god yeah yeah I just
forget to do it like yeah that's true
it's it's really hard there remembering
is the hard part it is hard you but
Annie do the stories those he's you're
fine yeah we're here like this is
technical Bob daily vlog every day are
you blogging us right now yes if you are
you gonna make this like looks tinny
into it I'm actually starting vlogmas do
you guys know what that is what is this
yes if you vlog every day until
Christmas oh that's hard I know I'm
really just terrified
finals next week yeah we got fine do you
find it difficult to balance like being
a student business owner um yeah a
little bit but actually just hired an
assistant shout out to Cali
um she's amazing and she just kind of
helps me film and like just do things I
can't did she go to UGA also yes Wow
so I went to UGA once yes can you please
tell me about your treacherous
experience do you know what what the
Greek grind yes I actually performed in
it I know that you're already yeah I'm a
Kappa Delta of course I'm at GMT and I'm
not yeah me too I'm a teen yeah you did
was anyone so I went to host agree
crimes like 9 to 3 years ago what are
you out of sophomore and sophomore so I
wasn't there yet you're so young so show
a complex isn't a dream so I went and
hosted it was like I'd never done any I
didn't hadn't been doing cnib I was like
the first time I ever really performed
not even perform like I just spoke in
front of people yeah and everyone was
really nice and welcoming until they
turned on me when I was talking about
chick-fil-a is like the girls found out
I never a chick-fil-a and they like put
in my dressing room it was so cute with
all the sauces and the chicken nuggets
and I love chicken I did some like I ate
it and they went out and I was just
talking about like you know chick-fil-a
and I'm like it's like it's chicken
nuggets it's like not that it's like
it's like McDonald yeah what's the
what's that crack and I got booed you
know yeah I feel like that was
definitely my last trip to UGA oh my
gosh oh so sorry about that experience
you know it was hard for me well you
know you should be really honored
because we always have like really cool
people host like that was talking at
Ashley I not okay well I don't know I
don't know that's what I just think we
should lightning on it they were like
right before you was Josh Murray oh my
god that is cool oh so you're like in
The Bachelor League that's exciting
that's because yes very when teg is he
like he's always there I've seen him
he's actually from okay I know you guys
don't love Florida but I am from Florida
yeah they just kick Casey Anthony not
even the crime rate just like the
quality of crimes are so straight yeah
enjoy words state we are fake but I like
yeah actually go to Florida very often
for how much it's just there no it's I
mean it's great you know it's a good
time okay we got a lot of questions I'm
gonna say look for maybe of all the
guests we've had we got the most
specific questions for you and they were
downright sleuthy
and I don't know what a lot of them are
referring they don't know if any of them
are crossed and I because I I've only
been a fan of your work for probably a
month now because what's so crazy is I
started using presets as everyone knows
and even know how to use them so I just
googled like how to use presets tutorial
and your video was the first one that
came up so I watched your video you
taught me how to use presets and then I
went to VI and you edited your video so
cute so I went to her page just to see
your flow and your flow was amazing and
then it said follow back and I was like
oh my gosh so I followed you back and
then we've just been like Instagram
friends ever since until now we're real
friends okay so if so I'm all of this
stuff that people are asking questions
about is predates predates our knowledge
of you totally this is from Katie K it
says give the people what they want the
dope drama oh my gosh I saw that
question okay so do you guys know what
dough is no so it's an online shopping
out basically and they've kind of turned
into like Mecca where they work with a
ton of influence there's like I went to
Coachella with them like a ton of people
it was like a really good time and I
guess people have noticed I stopped at
kind of working with them and there's
really nothing much really it's just
they like just work with so many people
and I just like didn't want to be like
in the crowd you know what I mean yeah
but I mean they're great it's a great
app you know that's okay so yeah
what are your go-to presets so this
one's less like a lot of drama starter
I'll mix it up no totally so when you
watch my video I was using this bloggers
presets yeah and now I actually just
downloaded her app and I just realized
that the filter the preset I use is
called toasty Oh Tessa yes I know I
heard about it tons of toasty yeah it's
I didn't even realize when I was on my
way here I was like I used to mention
your extra toes
extra toasty would you ever release your
own presets I would but it's just I
don't do that in like why bother you
know like yeah it's like I could change
one thing and sell it as mine yeah yeah
same preset for every single photo even
if it's not the right preset for the job
you got it you got it got to keep the
flow I struggle with that and so my flow
is a little like crazy but so am i I
have absolutely no clue
oh thank you are you single I am two
people slide into your DMS like to try
and [ __ ] um some like like you J
football playing right cool by the way
that would really help your flow like
that was a yeah
to find the one that's like going to the
NFL I know that's kind of the goal I had
a youtuber boyfriend that's I saw
someone ask big mistake Joey he's a
great guy we're still really good
friends it's just same field
yeah meet on YouTube on we met at an
event called play us live if you guys
know what that is it's just like a
YouTube convention that's cute
we're gonna get back together I don't I
don't know I think we're just kind of
paused he lives in Canada a really long
distance he'll see Swanson how do you
handle people's judgement and how do you
learn to not let it affect you like
people judging you for not having a
traditional career or how you spend your
money anything like that definitely
people I I like to spend money like I
can't mind I like the belt thank you so
much like I like to splurge on like
classic pieces and sometimes people are
like why are you doing that like you're
in college there's no need but I don't
know like I think it's really important
to like reward yourself something you
know so much money have a suitcase like
I could die I'm so proud of you that
they can you do that like personal
shopper thing I kind of do that oh my
god and it's free they had so people
don't understand you think you have to
pay for the appointment it's on the
fifth floor of Bloomingdale's I highly
recommend you to check it out okay I'm
just gonna rattle off go for it um this
is a very general question from Ali and
I don't know exactly what she's
referring to but spill some tea that
you've never smelled before yeah I just
I don't know um spill some tea I've
never spoken for I really I just I don't
know I'm literally the worst Thank You
general it's you I'm sorry I shouldn't
need specific I like hot mint tea okay
I'm actually referred tea what does it
haver food your favorite place you've
ever traveled to New York City I'm not
even kidding how am I is this how many
times you've been here I couldn't count
on to it like so many times I love it
like I almost went to college here like
I love it so much
where we gonna no I looked at Fordham
and then I also looked at have you guys
heard of L I am college it's like a
fashion merge I looked there to an MIT
so what's your major advertising so when
you graduate like I'm Trevor and ask you
to some people used to ask me it too
like are you gonna like get a job or
just gonna continue building your
business I don't know when that's my
struggle it's like final season and I'm
like I already like how this career but
like I love school and like I really
enjoy like the whole atmosphere of it so
it's like this balance of like like I
don't I don't want to go corporate and
I'm sure you guys don't you guys have
children if you did your job full-time
without school or even now you're
probably making more money now than you
would in an entry-level advertising job
that's why it hurts so much yeah but you
never know like the other day YouTube
like crash and I like how I think about
that all the time like if Mark
Zuckerberg died or something like we're
done we're all done yeah so they chose
to find another revenue stream that
major helps yes for sure so that's the
goal if you could date any celebrity who
would it be okay Josh Duhamel for some
reason oh that's a good one is so cute
and precious and recently obsessed with
Drake on a whole other spec yeah me too
my friend Leticia's mom yeah I'm Sam
it's like I think he'd be great for my
daughter I totally slid in just nothing
oh this is the question I saw that I
wanted to ask you from some shugged a
named Loretta what is it Brandon you
regret working with and like have didn't
have a good experience with any sort of
like really big corporate brand yeah
sounds like a lot of they're just it's
always like this
it's so nice working with a company and
then answer back but when they have to
go through all these different teachers
yeah it's so frustrating like I couldn't
name on tomorrow but any like just big
commercial company and you think it's so
exciting but they're just so hard to
work if they don't understand your brand
yeah they're doing you the favor yeah
also I just want to say the way you guys
infuse sponsorships in the podcast I
litter make weight that just happened
Thank You Camille thank you okay so we
have an advice question someone is your
age in college and wants to start a
YouTube channel but where does she begin
how do you balance it all so seamlessly
so I think the biggest thing is
consistent and just kind of if you want
to do it do it if you don't if you want
to do it for the wrong reasons it really
bothers me actually I want to be an
influencer okay I could literally she
knows I could literally go off like when
people just start it because they think
it can become something it's so apparent
and it's not authentic it's not
authentic like you guys love what you do
and that's why so many people follow you
for like what you do so many so like if
you want to start out I think that's so
great and so exciting but definitely do
it for like the right reasons and then
people see that and they're attracted to
it they want to subscribe yeah that's my
biggest tip of advice someone has two
good question
advice in terms of flow and I had I
thought it was interesting like do you
suggest someone wants to get into flow
yeah do you suggest them deleting the
photos reposting or just starting new
like that is the hardest part like
starting to low-key start the flow like
if you're using toastie filter you use
it at 50 for a while and then go up to
100 so it looks a little bit more I
think of that you know well what did you
do when you started using preset and ago
everything really I always heard about
my flow like I was using darkroom and I
was then I started when who cheeky man I
was using who do so much I always cared
about my he's great but then I took it
to just another level with presets like
who then I was you know getting the
blacks out and highlighted the pinks and
yellows so it's just yeah that just took
me to another level obsession and now I
flow everything do you like to know it I
don't I will do if people make my kids
out I don't have enough time to like the
photo and wait for it to pop up my email
yeah I truly don't
I do like like Commission links and
stuff on stories yeah like do you guys
ever swipe up beside you occasionally I
like something a hundred percent and
then I'm happy to see that it's reward
style I mean I would love to someone any
money from me I woke up this morning in
but a band ear jacket off of a Facebook
ad it's really cute
Oh cute yeah it was very brave of me
totally crazy what choices you out more
like YouTube work and that side or
school work school for sure well so it's
like school doesn't really matter I had
this so literally yesterday I took a
final and I was like having a pack for
this to make you last night and I was
like what do I focus on it's more of
like I stressed because I want to do
YouTube and I'm like I need to be doing
school yeah it's a one-person need and
it's so light it's just really
frustrating and hard and it's just would
you ever drop out
I would not drop out honestly the main
reason that's keeping my GP is just like
obviously you can stay at the school but
it's like you know our sorority a
certain GPA retirement so if you want to
be able to do the social things you you
know and my dad's got to be proud yeah
it's all day you can't drop out I wasn't
suggesting yeah no and I I mean I know
some people doing like totally good for
them and I love the school bag like
that's what you're having the best and
it's great for your flow all the pops of
red totally and the autumn leaves and
autumnal it's like just getting autumn
and it's like when you're here ya know
it's perfect for flow I suggest doing
thank you
so how do you balance like all of this
like prioritizing um what are your tips
for balance so my biggest tip if you're
a college student like I pack all my
classes into just Tuesday Thursday so I
can do weekend trips or whatever it may
be so that like Wednesday's are
definitely like a good in-between so I
get my schoolwork done and then like
Monday's are like I just crank out
content like will it go around take
pictures try answering whatever because
I try to post every day
you're like every other day just to keep
it going and I just vlog so it's just
the easy I just bring it along my life
and then I just added at the end of the
week yeah so did being YouTube famous
like help you get into a sorority where
people like oh that's girls question
sororities just such [ __ ] and it was
all about things like yeah and it's like
they care about the dumbest [ __ ] it's
like wow someone like famous is coming
through like we want to be a letter n'
letter so it's it's okay so actually one
of my really good you two best friends
Berkman she oh she goes to you J - and
she's a Kappa Delta as well so I think
that definitely helps because she like
knew who I was and I and one thing
unfortunate that's like looked upon in
our sorority it's like oh it's all those
famous girls but it's just truly not
that I mean you know but else you got
I'm just looking for new members yes we
have a ton of just people that really
appreciate like presets and just being
creative pinyin content and so I have
whatever told me that I think I'm a fun
gal but I think it I think I I don't
know
it's me Julia Chris did you use your
youtube to get into college like see
dragger i say that it is it was
definitely about it but I didn't get to
some schools like I really wanted to go
to school in Dallas for some reason and
they just denied me they don't so it
doesn't necessarily help
what was your essay um I remember well
my favorite quotes she believed she goes
she did so I like talked about that and
I talked about you to been like
balancing school with it and like
traveling at the same time and I don't
remember just about YouTube like
listening to you guys because it just I
just need to let's go you know thank you
for showing the toast in love I'm glad
that we could finally eat and
reciprocate the love of course everybody
keep up with the premium content on Jane
yells Instagram tell them where to find
you
so just Daniel Carolyn all over
Instagram YouTube all stuff thank you
for being here thank you toasters for
just a great week is a Friday it's
Friday
well doesn't feel like a Friday because
I'm headed to Alabama I can't wait to
see everyone tonight
and then I'll be back tomorrow to hang
out at my dog cam toes tickets Rahzel
going on sale Sunday noon Eastern Time
presale is for page our members and camp
toast one campers camp to us one campers
you check your emails today you're
getting something fun and then sale goes
on for everyone Monday noon when the
show ends Eastern Time so we're so
excited it's gonna be bigger and better
than last time n I can't [ __ ] wait I
can't [ __ ] wait I dream yes without
rules out or some have a great weekend
guys
you